we're back when we have the combination
Sisyphus lankans one two three four five
um so uh just a heads up I'm feeling a
lot better you can hear my voice now so
that's really good as evidence by the
fact that I'm sitting next to them and
not wearing a has man yes um and we are
going to get back to Steven universe I
don't know if we can get to it this week
but next week we definitely can uh so
you know we should probably be caught up
by next week I mean there's a lot of
episodes but I mean like I did I got a
few days where I can make room for it so
uh you might see more of those but you
know eat garnet and shit amethyst you
people and that's not it awful in every
conception of that that sounded all can
we will eat garnet and shit pearls mud
is smooth round
yes here's a colonic cleanser for you so
okay so because we are back with real
fast I haven't told Rob what we're uh
what we're doing yet but you know seeing
how this broke a million in like under a
month which for us is pretty quick uh
let's talk about alvin and the chipmunks
somebody um I love that movie I know
it's a little weird the way to go on a
hot air balloon chase not another not
that one it's the live-action CG Iowa
there is no live action okay okay fair
enough fair enough
Oh such a thing was nothing sis mr.
Simpson I hear you must have imagined it
I will save this it was not as bad as I
thought it would be because it's getting
said to transiting week won't get much
work that's like saying shitting pearls
is not as bad as shit again no you know
there's two things that I think are okay
what I feel like they had one good
writer in there and then like a bunch of
bad writers or Studio know there's some
problem what's there i riderhood
probably shot himself everything like I
tried to save it
I tried no no Niles David Cross oh and
that's the other thing I actually do
like he was sweet Jim at leaf um he is
legitimately funny in this and does
defend the movie and he's like he
doesn't say it's good but he's defending
like why he picked it and you know four
little kids are looking for a junk food
it's fine and he's kind of right he also
said he needed a house
don't worry he said something he hadn't
worked in six months like it was a long
long time it's not like this job Connie
ones paid for a house I gotta eat like I
gotta live somewhere so but he's
legitimately even though he's the
stereotypical just dumb bad guy he is
legitimately funny oh I laughed hard at
his they were just so passive-aggressive
yeah you know what reminded me of that
one if you've seen black books you know
what I'm talking about but it reminded
me and I always think you tap into the
two Simon pigs one-off character and buy
it books write laws want the same pain
wonderful
see yeah yeah I know you Diana
how can we fix this lead you to
something he's had he's doing the movie
he's doing the performance he's doing
what's required but he's kind of doing
it with a little yeah you you know what
I'm really doing gotta dirty the
character just comes off as like I say
it's passive-aggressive but it's more
like aggressiveness being barely masked
by passive idea I think it's just it's
almost aggressive aggressive but it's
just that quite and it's God it's great
to watch it's the only thing in that
movie then like this is amazing uh you
know it's like there's a scene where
Theodore comes up he's like I had a bad
dream and you don't supposed to talk
like you know down to this thing and not
be very loving and stuff but you know
it's like he's kind of doing the same
thing just like for the movies like and
this cute the things gonna come up he's
gets a I had a bad dream he's supposed
to go oh like that but the way he does
is like oh like aegis is he going oh I
have nothing but contempt for you yeah
like he's kind of trolling a little bit
I think was also the directors approach
to the movie yeah maybe the writers we
have nothing but contempt for you here's
some Chipmunks eating shit but every
once awhile you'd have a line like at
the very end there's a very funny line
where they're in like this little cat
cage or dog cage whatever this like
carrier case and you think it's gonna be
this big chase and then they're in the
car it's like well how'd you get out the
cage it's like we're Chipmunks that can
talk we can get out of a carrier cage it
wasn't even hard it was just like a pure
anticlimax I was actually kind of funny
that
one line was funny but it did I'm just
like wow you didn't even have the budget
for a client just like that the movie is
kind of thankful for that and I was
thankful for that because it came to a
merciful end yeah but at the same time
I'm like wow even by the low bar you
said the only reason to watch it the
only reason to have a climax would be to
see David Cross
like you know in the climax like saying
jokes and stuff like me to see David
Cross like pointing a gun to the
Chipmunks ass just like a hostage we
just think one of them you like yells at
one of them yeah like I wanted I wanted
more than I'm like now let's go full
batshit crazy with this oh and once in a
while the Chipmunks can be knighted just
Theodore's how about the way they
animated Theodore he was particularly
cute he was like just this little
fuzzball you like really really is so
weird about the movie is like going back
to the cartoon like can talk about the
Chuck Jones cartoon but I think most of
us don't even vote yeah most of the
people watching this grew up with the
80s cartoon we think Alvin the Jones
think that Alvin had a personality like
it was called yeah Alvin and the
Chipmunks he their zero personality zero
like I whenever Theodore and Simon R on
screen I'm not saying it was grape I'm
like all right it feels like the
Chipmunks are you know even Simon the
more I think about it wasn't really like
the intellectual or the egghead or
anything like that he never said
anything particularly smart very heady
or anything like that it was just
Theodore I felt I felt camarones but the
voice acting involved I felt more
emotion Simon maybe that as well as you
adore than I did out of Alvin no and
helping is like nothing you know and
he's supposed to be like the center he's
like he's got like the nostalgia Craig
we put maybe group he's like a egotist
he's always in the center like this he's
hogging the spot like here they get
stage fright which is like what you know
that's not the character of it I feel
like you could have you don't know how
they ever overcome it just put that
Alvin plushie and pulled the string and
have it say konichiwa
haven't danced or whatever was and like
that would have been just the exact same
thing we got like I felt like I was just
watching a plushie that occasionally had
yeah I mean there was just no there was
no personality to him which is so fun
cos Alvin has such a personality and all
the incarnations really even pretty
early on I mean he was just always like
he was the troublemaker he was the
egotist and everything and even like in
the show the other stuff it wasn't even
like Simon Theodore that would gain the
trouble he would sort of egg them on he
was the schemer and here they're just
all kind of troublemakers and that's not
as much fun and again the same problem
that plagues a lot of these stupid
movies these adaptations from like older
cards like when we need to tell the
Chipmunks origins story - I don't give a
shit about their origin story I'm sorry
I don't or gin story I don't care I'd
actually sort of sell kabadi allenge of
how do you tell it or just any with
Alvin - the Jenny buddy
remember the origin story in the cartoon
and I don't what's there an origin story
Ayanna I know buddy one of us so
YouTube's gonna be there but I bet those
people don't remember there's one
episode where there was like a guy who
came in say he was like their uncle and
he was like another chipmunk which again
was just raising questions of like oh
there's no other animals in this
universe and these shipments were like
you know yay hi they're like these
mutant Chipmunks I'm like how does this
work is like you're not our uncle like
but still raises the question there must
be some relation cuz there's only like
six of you in the world The Chipettes in
the cartoon I remember had an origin
story like some sort of little orphan a
like they're in jail a horrific Russian
orphanage or something it's a lacrosse
the sea and it was fucking bizarre had
this movie done that I've been all over
this cuz I'm like okay at least you went
from broke that that that's insane well
I like the fact that kept them Chipmunks
eyes I think that was a good idea dr.
Zhivago or something this epic tale like
but that's the thing wasn't really I
don't I don't know if I remember the
same backstory is I all I remember is
like something about an orphanage they
were in an orphanage they were trying to
get adopted like the evil owners of the
orphanage locked them up so they sneak
away and like hop on a boat literally in
like orphan rags like and try to make it
in Hollywood and are like walk in the
mean streets and selling their bodies
again oh my god
but I just remember as a kid like I'm
just like it was like epic like compared
to like this uh you just got that image
in my head and like them on the carters
you probably look like the cigarette
hanging out is like a you want to take
like this oh go to message boards
somebody I'm sure it's somewhere I'm I'm
sure by the time this video is over
somebody has done it in like the bags
under the eyes or like maybe a curler
and the hair that you're going to thing
up point being it was like some crazy
rags to riches story and this one I'm
just like this is so bored this is and
this is fucking Gen movie but with the
Chipmunks or was the Jim movie ripoff
the Chipmunks I don't know but they're
both ripoffs of that damn story that we
did a million times fucking story yeah
that just goes nowhere it's like oh and
the evil record producer is evil and
they get drunk on their success and they
realize that family is more important
and but it always strikes me as weird
because Jason Lee was such an asshole
yeah in this movie I you know I know
you're supposed to like feel for him
like in terms of like oh he's afraid to
have a family but it's like no he is
really like dismissive
um I just love it's like you're afraid
to have a family you're afraid to grow
up I'm like so adopt three chippings
that's like the person is just like oh
yes I have a child
it's mckiddy like there's a difference
between the childhood can I'm sorry well
and my favorite scene is well you know
they're like you know it's like
Christmas Christmas Day and they make
this little card saying you know we love
you and stuff I was like you know oh
wait just you guys know you know I'm not
actually your dad raising well you're
kind of like our Danny's like fuck you
or not yes guys like well no I'm not and
I'm just like what an a-hole who's
almost like a David Cross performance is
like no oh I've never been a huge Jason
Lee fan I'll be very honest I think
there's just hens he's not all brainy
but I can't get into him oh I I will say
this I did have this one joke because I
could not figure out why his voice was
so horror sound like me last week yeah
like the whole movies Alvin
yeah it's just joking that I'm like he
just goes to bed every night after
filming and screams into his periodic
calls to sleep I think that man that's
all I could manage well I remember like
when I was walking now see a movie or
SIA saw a poster for Alvin the Chipmunks
and I don't know why I was even
optimistic at all I was just kind of
like I grew up with that I wonder what
they're gonna do with that and then the
trailer play that exact same day
laughter I saw the pose I'm just like oh
it's it's this kind of movie hey Alvin
eat shit you gonna be big te ha ha oh my
that was that I think that was rock
bottom for me cuz you sit there me
telling your eighties cartoons were so
goofy you know what our characters
weren't like Alvin and the Chipmunks
they weren't eating shit all right
even by the low bar we said in the 80s
we were still a thousand times better
than this fucking monstrosity well and
from what I hear I hear they just get
worse and worse and worse
uh we probably will look at them at some
point I don't know where I mean she's
bricked the road chip chip buns
seasoned piece of chip he's the piece of
chip movie um so uh chip this is
bullshit um I really hate those scenes
where it's like the person is running
out and it's just like oh well it it is
if it isn't you still having trouble
with exposition exposition expert say it
is just so lazy when SH and hey I'm
sorry that one was not good I don't okay
I hate going that route because I don't
like to besmirching actors but I'll just
give her the credit and maybe she was
just doing this for a paycheck Oh
nature's got something else better
I don't remember who that was but
somewhere near the end I just was like
what the fuck is up with her
performances like yeah still not gonna
fan Oh what was that
hi oh I can't believe I said that hey ma
hey what's going on dance can't grow up
can cuz she was the heart of the movie
my friend ceci same old woman can't have
an actual emotion like she just was so
weird
yeah that sucked um I tried to man I'm
trying to go through like all the other
things in this movie in a sec you know
what else I'm glad this is kind of dying
as far as I know but kinda like that
inspirational music like when Dave takes
the the muffins as I go to do do do do
do do do do do it I feel like that music
was everywhere we was gonna begin the
night off
in the early 2000 a phenomena is shying
down but yeah it was kind of like I just
don't see those sort of movies cuz we're
grown-ass adults nothing to do that's
not a slam against seeing animated films
that's a slam against seeing stupid
these kind of movies huge differences
who's that guy who would always do that
music sometimes to be okay was it John
Debney is he sure one yeah he done like
now you're liar and and this is
Doubtfire
yeah we talked about what's why he could
turn a good scores down fire was Howard
sure oh you're right
you know I know how ya know that
nobody's okay music you're thinking
outward yes velocity was really like
hardcore John Debney
cast uh but once while he could do a
good score uh but yeah like you always
got him for that you know just mercy
yeah just person walking down the street
while the credits play and the music
we're head it's the joke about Randy
Newman about how Randy Newman just
scores you look don't dispute a book you
did it it's like the same thing by the
musical this is just like shut up
not every sit like okay that to me is
normally the sign of a bad comedy your
movie liar liar is the rare example
because I actually really liked it
it's goofy but you know most movies that
have a score like that that to me is the
last act of desperation it's like we
have nothing funny we
nothing interesting to look at
distracted with some cartoony score yeah
like not a whimsical cartoon yes car
because you can have cartoon but there's
it's like the whimsically funny
the music's telling you the laughs hey
you know I wonder is like a brand map I
wonder if like could you make the
argument that that kind of score maybe
you start with mrs. Doubtfire with
Howard Shore cuz that's actually not
that bad a score but why is just gone
back for those a type of score like the
consensus like the cartoony and the
whimsical you know kind of thing I guess
I don't you're like I feel like that's
always been around
yeah like Disney always had a lot of
that Oh watch like old like Disney like
live-action Disney Channel stuff yeah
but like that's uh you're right you're
right um Basia specific like in movies
but yet just Disney films that's always
kind of been there um but Howard sure
you never went on to anything no nothing
um so see he should get more attention I
know but maybe do fantasy I don't know
like a big fantasy like was like I don't
know
Potter things yeah like who scored
Potter James Horner right yeah yeah yeah
like like that guy uh yo else needs more
work John William
educate kind of does promote retire I
know I think any no no I think he needs
to stop oh no no yeah he's definitely
done poor bastards a workaholic female
ways retired he's still working yeah no
I love Joe ways it's like you can take a
break man I can enjoy retirements like
know there are more scholars movies
system that's I said oh I just I just
had to wasn't gonna say um it's like one
other thing oh uh comparing it to the
animated one you know the chipmunk
adventure I think we got to compare a
little bit oh well there's no question
about it the animated ones a thousand
times bit is but that's not but you know
what I hate him and be like make it's
nice kanji goggles I'm like yes there
are a lot of times in college is just
nothing to do in this dojo goggles
because I'll admit if I something a
little bit I've know if I saw the
Chipman if I saw the chipmunk adventure
as an adult I would be like okay this
was mostly pointless like this is
obviously intended for kids but I would
be like you know this is really good
animation
yeah and like in the creative
entertaining it's fun it's bizarre
Jonah Diamond smug sister like
everything was a balance muddling and
you know eventually if kids what they
wanted like yeah kid which okay if
you're a kid which would your NC o some
like story about how the Chipmunks get a
record deal like with an asshole and
they're their asshole like and then
mostly in the house and and there's
girls than name never grow up man and
listen what or hey we got diamond
smuggling we got alligators
we got signaling the danceable going
across the globe hot-air balloons it's
crazy it doesn't make any sense but
you're gonna see shit man every racist
stereotype you can imagine s'right
that's the eighty and that's how we
fucking roll I'll try else again some of
that movie again it's like that the
Mexican part isn't that bad but like
when they go to the tribe I don't even
know where that's supposed to be is just
but whoever it is I'm kind of like my
favorite Gene Wilder is gone god bless
him all of the clips they're digging up
for miseries I was looking up you know
Blazing Saddles could make that nowadays
my favorite was like first Gene Wilder
movie ever saw was actually Silver
Streak the dad had put it on I'm
watching attic a while to do blackface
I'm just like oh my god you couldn't
have like 19 this happened in 1976 you
won't know when it I watch that movie as
a seven-year-old in the early eighties
you want a white at work so is cuz he
does it so poorly well maybe that's why
you can still get what they rewrote it -
apparently Richard Pryor was like fuck
this he was gonna walk off the film
we're getting off track yeah Richard
Pryor was good to chip and Louie who
gives a fuck sister Richard Pryor was
gonna walk off the film like we want
she's like fine so he and Gene Wilder
rewrote the scene to a point where
Richard Pryor is like okay I think we
can do this and I can still maintain
myself fucking dignity and so it is a
very funny scene it it fucking works
because they worked on it down but yeah
like 80s 70s and 80s man
what the fuck yeah just um I'll take it
over yes alvin and the chipmunks yeah
I'll still take that um but yeah there
was just kind of like this you know it
was there was even though lots of things
you can point to are wrong with that
movie stuff but there was an ambition to
it and there was this idea there's like
it's for kids we know we can kind of get
away with anything it's animation let's
get away with anything and let's really
do something with the animation this was
a thing back when we were kids and we've
completely lost it completely lost that
concept of oh you're doing a movie like
base on a children's properly let's make
it big and amazing give kids something
they want up the ante I'd argue a little
bit like the lego movie I think they're
doing they like to come from Panama
visas yes okay come to Panda nut based
on a property Lego may be the only one
it's based on a property but I son
that's based on property that's true
then like a like okay in Alvin and the
Chipmunks cartoon now we're gonna make a
movie The Smurfs cartoon yeah now we're
gonna make em you know transformer and
and the funny thing is like they take
these probably like when we were kids
you would want to see these things it
would be like oh my god we're gonna see
things we couldn't see on the small
screen kids nowadays you get diminishing
returns it's like you're gonna see less
than what you got on the fucking cartoon
ship oh yeah it's one of those things
where it's like when they made a movie
it's like oh it's like a movie like big
things are gonna happen and now it's
just sort of like okay this story these
things we would I think our heroine of
matrix reference throwing these songs
these ads if you're good we would bake
our parents to see them and if I were a
kid and I saw this album Chipmunks movie
first I would not beg to see the sequel
no it's so fricking like Squeakquel
thank you very much Squeakquel
I'm sorry what in the blue chip I
remember seeing the trailer for the
animated Chipmunks that was really
excited cuz it just looked like it had
everything I mean cuz there's so much
you can show from that movie that looks
so friggin cool uh so there is something
got you excited like I mean obviously
kids saw the chipmunk movies I don't
think they're number one of the box
office but they got their money back
they were hits enough you know and uh
yeah I mean kids want to see you know
cuz her is small and cute and tee hee ha
ha but it's like I definitely works I
did you know I do kind of Miss that
excitement of seeing something that you
watched or you can grow up with where it
is a movie oh you're too handsome there
are two sets of movies they were the
movies you were really excited for Bob
this is amazing and there was they
moving it your parents are just like
we're gonna take you to see this mostly
because it couldn't have anything better
to do and you sat in your watches I Oh
like that is a nice distraction but
that's it like I feel like more and more
it's just becoming the latter like it's
like oh this is something to distract
you and I feel like there's a cynical
part of Hollywood that it's like well
that's all we need like this just give
the parents want to get out of the house
they just want to shove their kids in
the movie news feed him shit well and
there is uh Lansing is you talking about
here cuz I did bring up in the review
was when I call him I think the all
girls I think that's what we call them
um they really do exist and I know this
because my mom is one of them she's like
one of the things she's seen all the
chipmunk movies just finds them so II
just okay this is my problem though cuz
like we had this discussion cuz I'm like
let's not stereotype all girls
everywhere oh no no no no no what
bothered me about that is like you know
everybody its Tamra and what was he at a
Heather and I yeah it what bothered me
about is I felt that was the wrong age
group most people I know who like this
movie are freaking baby boomers like
know what I like people over the age of
50 no I'm not gonna lie I actually go
almost everybody I know like our mother
my mother's friends friends of friends
you know the church lady when I was
getting to know cuz I remember uh I was
in college I came here when the first
one came out but I do remember there's
just like this group of girls you know
like my beeped Ecology girls you know
something like that that were uh just
talking about just how cute it was
they're gonna do in the days and they
were doing it was just but yet it was
clearly intersection they just wanted
you were hanging out with some wrong
girl oh no no I mean this was just a
side conversation you know like I could
just hear it over there and I have heard
that before I pre heard you know like
whatever high school girls or college
girls or something like that just
because it's cute and it's cuddly and
but like you said just kind of
you know junk food distraction you know
kind of thing I'm not saying they don't
exist I'm saying I haven't met them
everybody I know who likes this movie is
already a chief isn't below me or under
the age of ten yeah I was almost gonna
have um my mom as one to be August shoot
but but then I was realizing like you
know we're do a big musical number yeah
right well now that wouldn't work don't
but that's the then under 10 and over 50
that is the demographic for this movie
you know I know what it's like you know
like that those who don't know there's
better things to live for and those
who've given up on life I wasn't kind of
like you know how to kill me by the way
if we hit that age and we like a movie
like that oh you know how some people
watch something ironically like it's not
that but I feel it is kind of like now
you know I've had a long way about it
yeah just but turn my brain on see
something cute and it's like Chipmunks
was Cathy bug what are they funny if we
saw them he's so cute and be so like I
don't know these are conversations I've
heard once or whether stab myself in the
eye with a drinking straw oh yeah we
would yeah but um yeah but that's
definitely conversations I've heard
before and I was it you know if that's
your thing okay I mean it's not like
harmful it's not like a better cute
movie but yeah I feel like there's a lot
of better get what maybe there aren't a
lot of better cute movies well then you
know we only get them once in a while
like anime feels have gotten a lot
better and they do have these cute
characters and everything but yeah I'd
be like I said there was like a ton of
them see something enriching this do
something better with your lives better
your dance
um so oh you were talking about ambition
I so I found it hung out if what I
what's been told to me is true one of
the reasons it looks so good because I
when I was when you show me the the clip
cuz I hadn't seen the movie think when
you and Lindsay did it I saw it but I
hadn't seen it still in a number of
years now like I was like okay and again
I'm like wow I forgot how really
freaking good this animation well yeah
at the anime was yeah the animated one
I'm like it's a freakin Chipmunks movie
there is no excuse there was no reason
this should have animation that's good
but I'm like this is literally a dice
not making this up like watch it trust
me this is Disney animation that did it
as good and in some cases maybe better
than Disney than Disney was doing in the
middle of the 80 yeah yeah we thought of
that that was the dark ages for Disney
and that's why that's when Care Bears
beat the black culture
yeah when Care Bears beat the black
called it now funny thing this ties it
all together from what I heard and maybe
this isn't true but from what God told
to me was apparently what happened is
Black Cauldron was such an effing
disaster for Disney that there were
layoffs there was and we don't know what
we're gonna do is a NAMBLA yeah blue 3
you had Bluth in Amblin you know
operating at the same time they picked
off a bunch of Disney so Disney
basically was in the shitter and either
Disney had let some of their animators
go or some of the animators realize that
this was a sinking ship so all of a
sudden the MGM out of nowhere has a
bunch of Disney quality animators from
Disney on their little chipmunk project
do you wanna know what I think if that's
the case it frickin show you all know
what I think happened to cuz if you
watch the animated Chipmunks again like
half of it
it's stellar animation like I say I mean
the whole thing does horde you look
white everything yeah no but then the
other half kind of looks like just kind
of a slightly high budget episode you
know there you go yeah you know cuz the
Sheldon and great animation Locker tooth
back then didn't but you know this looks
like a high budget version of like you
know the show but then the other half is
just like gorgeous you can totally tell
I bet you anything that they were
working on this movie and then like when
Black Cauldron happened or that split of
like a bunch of the animators to Disney
animators or something like come with us
come over here yeah maybe they took over
it could be I don't know if it was that
or MGM just literally assigned them to
certain scenes like ringers you know
just like okay well let's make these
bits look really good like I have no
idea what it but I when I watch it I'm
like this shouldn't exist there's no way
a Chipmunks movie should have scenes
this gorgeously animated ya know but
like I said I think with I kind of want
say with anything with a in this case
stuff and I believe in smaller movies
you know you need smaller movies and
stuff but I think if you are going to
take some things if you're gonna make
movie make it big because like I said
I'm thinking back to a trailer I
remember I saw like you know the
Chipmunks you know battling sharks the
Chipmunks flying around the world the
chitlins ah you know in Rome doing these
rocking scores with fireworks going and
the Chipmunks leading the Scottish
against the English and chuffing freedom
it wouldn't be shocked you know and just
them doing all these cool things and you
know and like people you know all around
the world people throwing spears and
then like you know now they're in the
Atlantic or uh you know just suddenly on
the snow and igloos and stuff and like
it's just something where it's like it
felt so huge and so big and you're right
I think when they do properties now it's
like oh oh there's Doug in Manhattan
because I think they're just going for
the cute and again I think they're going
for kind of like that all-girls thing
they're going for like the you know
people like our moms you know or art mom
sorry justice when you just mentioned
all of those things that I think about
how the new movie opened would just
they're sad and depressed and shoving
acorns or deuterium having the Chipmunks
nothing yay so you had a bad days being
sped up and that was it just like te ha
ha I know that song and it's a high
pitch now ha ha that's it like you know
and I don't know the first of all both
like the clouds and this beautiful text
and this score that was like today
you're gonna get an attention you know I
I don't know even that just like that
song and until you get a get dimension
Wow huge it is it yeah and I I why even
it why'd you just make the whole fucking
thing you animated that's what I do I
know drives too much maybe but I then
why are you doing it like it I know it
because apparently I made money and
that's clearly you can see so it's wrong
oh he was wrong somehow I know there's
gonna be a million comments saying that
the squeak walls are worse I trust you
uh yeah you don't need to tell us that
we I will say as as bad as film was we
could figure that out actually without
anybody telling her as bad as this film
was I will say there were some things
that like I said David Cross was fun
sometimes you know they were low Kuhn
sometimes there was a good
line you know uh so there was at least
that I'm so my kinda like well you don't
assignment to a certain extent had some
personality whenever they were on screen
and they weren't doing something
insanely stupid okay this kind of feels
like albumin trimmings is not much going
on but it's not offending me yeah uh and
then they eat shit Oh Alban sister so
yeah that's about it uh hopefully more
videos are gonna be coming your way I'm
just catching up with NC stuff and
everything and next week we'll get the
Steven universe back on track the V logs
and uh we shall see you guys then so
later mmm really
you're not gonna say it back gonna say
it now you're not gonna say it no I'm
not gonna say it I coulda say huh